rolling up to JFK feeling pretty good
Detroit
quick quick he nope Dan Gilbert and his
whole family businesses what are the
cabs quicken bunch of the businesses of
amazing American entrepreneur quickly
back to the airport headed to our London
78 hours of London meetings repeater
London that boom went on planes commerce
Germany quick shower right into the
speaker's dinner that night get to sleep
give a keynote slipping right back to
NYC
I'd like to thank all the men and women
in the Armed Forces who wouldn't be able
to follow my dreams that they weren't
for them I get nervous for a show then I
put it all to the side when I breathe a
lot you wake up in the middle of the
night it's a fight for my freedom I
pledge my allegiance ball play I think
everything suffers hop I think they feel
at home because I feel like I'm a parent
and I take all my actions between the
room they live in and so when the
psychology I deploy and the listening
and the talking you know I think people
only feel at home when the parents make
it feel at home I think it's the job of
every Smith sorry on behalf with the
people that just ignore you weed I know
the funny religion if I did yes but this
is concern actually giving a [ __ ] about
people instead of how much money they
make because a funny thing happens when
you give a [ __ ] about people you end up
making more money people when every
single Walker life is carrying it some
people and so a lot of people gonna get
my worst twisted I'm a good guy training
good vibes on the mission I want I mean
I think some portions those companies
should then make what is appropriate and
all the people that work there they're
more than welcome to start their own
companies or work somewhere else you
know this whole narrative of like these
businesses or [ __ ] yes do i want
businesses to care about people more yes
it feels nice and it feels right at the
legacy I want to leave and I think
you'll actually make some more money but
do but the employees aren't being slaves
is not laboring everybody has to be
accountable this isn't just a man [ __ ]
up where the business is [ __ ] up the
employees [ __ ] up in earnest shift
situation instead of going home at five
o'clock and drinking beer and
complaining
go on [ __ ] job listings in urban
networks find a different [ __ ] job
the good cafeteria the free you know
granola I just think that's worship
those are tactics potential companies do
to try to make people the people
inspired and feeling good because they
feel clean and they feel like they can
grow they feel like safe and they feel
like they can grow that's the [ __ ] that
matters not [ __ ] three Cheerios on
[ __ ] human language and you guys have
to hound me until you get this out of me
which is with you guys and the and the
SVP of the business and I'm probably
going to start bringing you guys to them
one of you so that it's even faster but
I think a lot of times will be the first
time like like the guys wouldn't have
brought you two you know what I mean
your job is to not let me off the hook
after I have a senior client meeting for
like more like inspiration we I like
putting up signs and I do that [ __ ] but
I don't think people have been or are
happy and killing it because I have a
picture of me saying your funeral
matters that's up there that's tough
there because I like that you know like
like not because that's there is a
tactic it's all religious we have to
feel safe and they have to feel like
they can grow you know and that's it and
like everything at like nobody's not
going to put people by having 24-hour
massage in a [ __ ] room you know what
I mean band-aids
everybody's got band-aids nobody gives a
[ __ ] about your hardwood floor or the
soda fountain machine the nice butt and
we have them but I'm not the one who's
ever making that happen that's other
people my company that supplied those
things I've known Justin Bandys [ __ ]
work because I give a [ __ ]
she's drunk this is a man about it I'm
serious
they're the best thing that it affecting
something actual phone you look crazy
that thinks it's the actual thing
all right Nate I gotta go I got a friend
here okay love you bye so you exploded
the whole time
Steve honestly on a very search on a
very serious note what you should have
holding trimmin she'll finish up you
should do that know what's great about
this enough it's do anything no [ __ ]
doing yeah yeah and that's weird and it
takes a few minutes to like get that
you're pretty weird but it's getting way
less weird we how many meetings have we
been in where now that's two people
doing it like the other it's it's a
foregone conclusion and we very rare
never I like some kind Swami - I mean
very rarely and we never put anything
that's you know there's never been think
I F at it's the only the only downside
is that the watch it because I might say
something that I can't control I'm going
to say something that you're the editor
you I'm screwed yeah no no it's it's
what I do
I watch it and I and you know after a
while the team kind of knows but you
still got it like you know you're saying
something that's subtle
you're awesome
you know Alex alone Zach Nadler and
Tyler and tell them I'm really into
fireside chats because it makes me doing
stuff it's reasonably - silly question
for you
we need your arch-nemesis your proudest
mission Tom Brady okay
and Michael Jordan I'm putting - okay
how does mission proudest mission is
becoming the foundation of my family
thank you thank you so much we walk
around like we own this place that we
own this place we walk around and we own
this place that we own this place we
love the ground and we on our way oh
yeah all right you have the Creelman
I'm so proud of you I knew you're gonna
time you're so funny
I literally went in through him lives
because he walk away and I wanted to
feel bad and meanwhile I didn't guys
don't so horrific
d-roc did it he left his camera right
here the whole time
all right and he knows me he knows he's
so well because how [ __ ] up I am see
Rocco's took a pastor I don't know what
the hell you get did good great and I'm
ignoring his one children live he's
gonna come back and you really sad that
he left out on like ten minutes of
footage unbelievable
anyway thank you up thank you all for
love
Sergei good to see you angel good to see
you how do I develop my level of
patience vcn px5 brother there's just no
other way other than just doing it right
like you know you just be like you feel
like you get you should make this gonna
be the rock rock where your face is the
only thing you know anyone
anybody things that make sense right
absolutely right whether you're the
owner two tabs home about the bone stays
with or you're a Cavs fan in the last
row I'm actually in here only to be
Thursday and years you just bully you
like that have different thank you like
you have given it was given topic topic
right but I love them think tonight
haven't done anything yet they know that
they know that right every day like
existence literacy six months about
lazily yo legit garrison shop calm and
then I've got the book in January and
the vaynermedia thing I don't know how
many of you were part of live stream
last night but this was awesome I I came
up with a new business and I've been
thinking about it but Zappos and Disney
cell tours so we're gonna do that at
vaynermedia from the program just paid
media video production I'm also did you
see it and you can see the female I'm
also going to film it the whole thing
and all ten people are going to do an
interview of six questions I come up
with and we're going to give them a
piece of content to leave what kind of
on the manifesto how do you start
[ __ ] awesome right
that's what I'm trying to figure out how
like people like holy [ __ ] for $10,000
yeah like if you can make something work
forget that that's it that's it and the
keynote took me like Ashton Kutcher Tony
Robbins [ __ ] like you know fairness
Kevin Road it's going to people have a
[ __ ] worse is the whole day 11 hours
immersive and then you gonna make
connections to so think about the
like-minded people then you're there and
be like a you want to go out to dinner
we're gonna me and me came up a subject
we're gonna send people to certain in
response where they're gonna get hooked
up hunting fish club places like oh so
like randomly I'll be there too but and
we've got some ideas like flag packs and
like I basically how do we make it work
a hundred pretend anyway if you're
interested to be part of the first group
they'll be remarkable the best day you
ever spend can change your game forever
very focused detail [ __ ] not just not
the motivation stuff that's for free
how we execute paid campaigns in size
you think about video so you should be
thinking about bigger talent like
[ __ ] Rio
I'm going I'll come in an answer
question for the school obviously
business in video production strategy
global strategy how you do the ad how
you make the video designers are how we
brainstorm ideas of the usual all right
it was just about starting so many we
were stuck cm started and so I've
actually the first time my career like
literally it's not with their family
it will never flew this yacht right like
literally sends eyes attacks like what I
want to make it's just not how I usually
do stuff but clicks so important to me I
broke it down into that what how and way
are right that's what every one of you
could have not started your business was
started your personal brand or building
your oil you can make something and that
thing is a manifest they're just classic
video I'm anything back in the day while
I was on a London flight there was this
kind of a cross-section it wasn't kind
of whatever could no no one who's
reporting aside if it's not thought
where I was at at that moment I'm
content of [ __ ] actually fun to look
back exactly right right I was kind of
like you guys don't know right it's
gonna be cool like anyway nonetheless
they just don't know me they don't
understand what I'm going to do they
don't understand that it's early
people just don't forget how early it is
36 of a kid every one of you needs to
sit down and make a piece of contest
whether and this is now the house
whether this is video form whether this
is party of one and whether this is
written born right audio being a podcast
right hack you in the do pocket put the
record on your phone and just speak your
truth get in front of a camera
selfie spouse or set it up on a tripod
or have a d-roc your nephew or sister
your aunt
the daughter I don't care or you write
it but the way all of you need to do
this and how you actually start and by
doing so first you start with I'm gonna
talk about I've broken that down for you
I fix before you hear did tell the world
either how you're feeling right now and
or what you're about to affect I'm done
giving you guys the top-line strategy
I'm a little detail this is it this is
how you saw me I'm gonna help you right
now
either tell people how you're feeling
exactly right now and what you're
thinking about yourself about the world
about the State of the Union of coffee
or tell me what you're gonna do right
tell me and no I say [ __ ] you're gonna
need to put it out there your stuff you
haven't started cuz you're stuck so here
you go what what I'm going to talk about
what do you want to be known for you
want to be in health and fitness you
want to be in strategy you want to in
social media you want to be in sneakers
you want to be in coffee you want to be
in electronics and want to be in any
fashion I don't care let's meritocracy
are you kidding me you love good theater
yes I love correct both how can it be
very easy when you're pulling from both
sides you win the contradictions are
where all the magic is you want to be
successful go fast don't give a [ __ ]
about what anybody thinks about you you
want to go fast and win care about what
every single person says about you yeah
empathy matters as much as ego it's the
balance of the opposite thing that
allows the winners to really win I Know
Who I am
Oh everyone when I'm a million but not
everybody been working everybody knows I
got brilliant but not everybody better
see everybody wrap our money hoes but
think I need everybody knows I mean when
the legacy reprise I I dictate the
tempest us that matters to me the most
I'm a dictator on remember send that
matter to me loads and then it's open
for everybody on the 90% and then
rewarded people that are winning a great
job yes short-form and long-form yes
here's a lot that you do and because
billion to long-form content every
content will no change overnight no
remember how I said headline readers
versus practitioners the headline sounds
right like you would bat make it short
sure or it's a three-hour movies awesome
people will sit watch it it's just
completely based on the content you have
any here that's what I do long form and
I want you to be honest I take lot of
your questions I have a drink this and I
love it and it is a little bit longer
and I mentally if it's good people will
watch you talk about beer
yeah lateral yes so how do you by
talking to them communications
communications the only thing that
solves anything ever enjoy so far the
best part was like I know you'd like you
get up and do your thing
yeah and I'm like I see the two trips
and games it's right interview that's
going to go great it was unbelievable
that one suggest people hired doing like
doing what will separate you is doing
actually making content like actually
doing like when you walk in like sis how
I build my Instagram or this is how I
thought about pre-roll on Facebook or
this is how I made a long-form bit like
it can actually can public I design
these filters on snapchat doing okay I
don't have a company here I'm done
hi Dan yep great i doing doings always
the answer
awesome yeah nice to meet you well folks
good yeah good man's good
alright yeah yeah just kind of question
yep okay nice to be judge want to try
garbage action yeah let's do it so he's
kind of wait I'm going to like miss my
[ __ ] place everything I wanted not
got it I was one of more so whenever
beat that mean everyone napkin when a
new dress being pressure been building
but it's a good problem graduated
college and never got options I was
bringing more about these repete car
she's always been busting everybody
watching them every business no you're
not
I feel like support like in 20 years and
I have that thing and the me coming up
does it
everybody will respond well to it cuz
it's that pure form up here I keep on
going to the light go down yeah till the
lights go down
nice dog I'm trying to figure out how
big of an impact I can have at this kind
of budget level which will then give me
leverage to buy businesses you know I
mean I'm going to place right now with
my career where I'm getting the kind of
emails I get are so strange
entrepreneurs are funny now they're like
I'll give you 40 percent of my business
to be my partner and we're doing seven
figures is like I'm a little getting
weird like to come in it with all the
nothing not know the future gonna give
me nothing not putting the time putting
the work of my rom the well along oh my
shot I'm on down here so lol offense man
in the middle of doing whatever but
don't down what number they will change
me people thinking I'm crazy think it
needs a lot of players we've pushed it
he misses flight I'm not going to London
it's my good well no money you people
the blend wishing that everyone started
with millions of dollars and do what
they wanted I wonder how many would
governor college of one of the trees in
our worries are fall in this room
everything I used to dream here will
right now now now if it wasn't working I
will work it out out out yeah I keep on
going to the light go down yet till
device
down down down till the night go down
down down I'll be feeling alright I'll
be taking what's mine I'll be running
outta time imma keep on going up till
the lights go down war me up to your
life life 25 in your jet that's me